-For those who couldn't tell
from the clip,
you are three women.
This is --
You are committers of crimes.
-That's true. Yes, it is.
We did commit a crime
in the pilot episode.
We will continue
to do bad things.
-Yeah. And it's really fun.
It's a super funny show.
-Thanks.
-And a fantastic cast.
You, Retta,
and Christina Hendricks.
Were you immediately --
Did it become clear to you
were working with great people
right away?
-Oh, yeah. Right away.
I mean, the whole concept is
these women grew up together
and they all kind of get backed
into these financial situations
that are really desperate.
And it's kind of desperate times
call for desperate measures.
But I think one of the really
important elements is
that we really believe
that they're all
really close friends.
And so we actually ended up
having a producers' dinner
the first time we all three,
kind of, hung out together.
And it was very formal.
We had a nice cocktail.
and then we sort of were like --
The producers went home
and we were like, "Mae, should
we have a nice dinner?"
Sure. So we went to dinner and
had about seven bottles of wine.
[ Laughter ]
Then we were like, "Should we
keep having a nice time?"
And we went
to Christina's house.
And all I know is somewhere
around the 3:00 mark I believe
I was like, "I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go to the restroom."
And Christina -- apparently,
I just never came back.
And like an hour later --
[ Laughter ]
Like an hour later Christina
went looking for me
and said her front door was ajar
and my pants were splayed out
on her dining room table.
And she, like, wandered into the
street and was like, "Mae?"
Like, with my pants thinking I
just wandered into the ocean
with no pants.
But I just stole some of her
sweatpants and went home.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty classy stuff.
-That is classy.
-That's me, guys.
-There you go.
-Invite me over.
-That seems like
a real rookie move,
but you've been doing this
a long time.
-I did it on purpose, okay?
My character is irresponsible.
I was trying to
generate a relationship.
-You were deep in character.
-That's right.
I would never do that
in real life, Seth.
-Of course.
-You know me. Come on.
-Well, you're very --
Well, you have been doing this
since you were 3 years old.
-It's true, yeah.
-You've been in the business.
And you had parents
who were very --
wanted to make sure
you were ready for this.
-Yes, Pat and Jeff.
They are extremely good
caretakers.
They really wanted to prepare me
and actually
they may have prepared me
a little too much.
There's a classic story that,
you know,
on a movie set everybody curses
like sailors.
Like, it's the most intense
place to be.
-And so they said, "Okay, we're
gonna sit her down."
And they said, "Now listen, Mae.
You're gonna hear
a lot of words.
And we want to tell you what
they are
and we're gonna tell you
exactly what they mean,
but you must
never, ever use them."
And they, you know,
gave me the whole spiel.
The meanings, the words,
all of them.
And so apparently a couple days
later they got a call
from my next door neighbor,
who I was best friends with
their kid at the time,
And the mom said, "Come on over
and see what's happening here."
And they peeked over the fence
and I was sitting in the pool,
and I was going,
"Now, here are the words.
This is what they mean but you
must never, ever use them."
[ Laughter ]
To, like, this like 4-year-old
and her 2-year-old brother.
So yeah, you know, my best work.
-Very helpful.
-Full disclosure.
-So, Sarah Jessica Parker
was just here.
-I know.
-You are obsessed with her,
but kind of recently.
-Cool it. She's probably still
in the dressing room, Seth!
-She probably still is, yeah.
Yeah, she's probably taking
your mug right now.
-Oh, she probably is.
She can have it.
She can have anything.
I've got a wallet.
Take the cash.
Whatever you need, SJP.
-But this is -- you --
"Sex and the City," this is --
-Yeah. I tend to come into
things a little too late.
because whenever I start,
like, a new show or something,
it really means a lot to me.
And I get so invested it's hard
for me to do anything else.
So I just started
"Sex and the City"
like literally like a month ago.
[ Laughter ]
Retta was making so much fun of
me, 'cause I'd walk into set
and be like, "Oh, my God,
Carrie cheated on Aiden!
Can you believe?"
And she was like,
"Yeah, 20 years ago.
It's pretty wild
to go through that."
It's really sad.
[ Applause ]
I know. I'm trying. I'm trying.
-Do you just do it for
everything, not just that show?
Come in and be like,
"Lewinsky, have you heard?"
-Guys, it's crazy.
You don't understand.
I really -- the one other area
that I really struggled in
is the "Hamilton" train.
It took me for freaking ever
to get on it.
And Retta was, like,
so annoyed with me.
I mean, literally the only thing
I knew from "Hamilton"
was when the "Hamilton"
challenge came up,
Lauren Graham, who's still like
my best friend in the world.
We actually went hiking
in the mountains
and afterwards she was like,
"We're doing the challenge."
And she taught me one song.
So that's, like, all I had to
relate to people at parties.
I was like, "Oh, I know.
When she goes
♪♪ a toast to the groom ♪♪
and like does the whole thing
I was like,
Ah, that's crazy, right?
I've got to go though.
I'm gonna run out."
But Retta,
when she heard about this,
she totally flipped out
and she was like,
"We're going this trip."
So I went last night
for the first time!
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. It was so exciting.
-I'm always worried
that people who wait too long,
they'll hear
so much about "Hamilton"
that they will then
be underwhelmed.
But that does not seem like --
-I couldn't believe it.
First of all, something really
humbling happened
when I was coming back in,
where I got there a little late
and I have, like, a really
nightmarish peeing problem
where it's like
every five minutes.
I'm like, "Well, now I have to
pee. I'm not enjoying the show."
So, like, I go like right
before the show starts.
And when I came back in --
also the show "Good Girls" had
just premiered the night before.
And when I came back in,
people kind of started to look
in my direction,
and they were like,
oh, kind of excited,
taking out their cameras.
And I was like,
"You guys, please.
It's really not a big deal."
And then literally
the three people
in front of me
turned around
and it was, like, these three
beautiful blonde people.
And it was
the gold medal Olympians
from the cross country
skiing team.
And literally everybody's like,
"Get out of the way, excuse me,"
like, pushing me aside.
And I was like, "Oh, okay, yes,
I mean, it's amazing."
So that was pretty cool.
And yeah, I mean,
my mind was blown.
It's the most amazing thing
I've ever --
-I just want to point out
how kind Retta is
that she would take you
to that show
after you made this observation
on Instagram.
You put a picture of Retta
next to a picture of The Rock
and you said, "When your costar
shows up to work
looking like The Rock."
And I got to say
it's a pretty fair --
-I mean, you guys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You guys -- it's the exact --
-It's the exact same outfit.
-It's literally
the exact same outfit.
-You added the fanny pack.
-What do you mean?
That is a real fanny pack, Seth.
I would never
do something like that.
-Hey, congrats on the show.
It's always so great to see you.
Mae Whitman, everybody.